this year we wanted to celebrate 10
years of best new menswear designers and
we wanted to do it with an all-star team
GQ best can't say new best bends where
designers in America or the gap
there's been dozens of winners over the
years and it was hard to win it down the
four designers this year are Michael
Bastian John Elliott Steven Allen and
Saturdays he said the GQ all-stars we
are on our way to see Michael Bastian
instead of just doing items we're
encouraging them to make an entire
collection of four to five looks head to
toe for the gap I saw how much fun we
wanted to distill their style down to
their DNA for the lucky shoppers of gap
and the readers of GQ it's a greatest
hits collection oh yeah Michael Bastian
is a phenomenon really he was a retailer
that found a real void in the market for
real clothes that had great style and
great fits no one's really kind of
jumped on some awards I remember my dad
flipped one on ice one time we had
dirtbikes brains that's why your clothes
look like this we'd be remiss not to do
this he's gonna be a good one
is he in that moleskin yeah and this is
just like our basic button I mean yeah
it's just so perfect is that a tweed
jacket that's a tweed jacket that we
talked about with the tech and the
shorts so that is incredible
Wow we are so excited Michael Wow
I thought it was a total home run I'm
not even sure if we're gonna expect that
kind of perfectionism for me everybody
Steven Ellen has been someone that we've
nurtured from the very beginning we meet
six or seven complete looks head to toe
and we're here to kind of just make you
dial it up a little bit yeah I didn't
know I didn't know that was I'm a little
surprised that you know some of them
have had you know almost a month to
prepare this it's not here I don't see
any you know I guess it's like a school
project you know you kind of wait till
the last minute
Stephen Allen is the old guard in New
York it's like when I think about his
reverse seam shirt you know 20 years ago
you kind of created a new wardrobe you
know where you still wear that suit that
you have to wear a tie you still wear a
shirt but you can wear it on top what
would you think about doing a corduroy
suit that would be really fun to do I
like that right you also have a great
pattern for a coach's jacket with the
snaps everything yeah guys I love this
weight of shirt I think that would be
great
and then do a tween time I think that's
a good idea that's our weekend back well
that's incredible I think this is a must
okay we got your work cut out for you
all right
we've always been influenced by New York
City and all these different kind of
cultures that are experiencing it so we
focused on New York
Saturday's three awesome guys who are so
crazy about surfing they wanted to
create a lifestyle collection around
this guy that spends his weekends at the
Rockaways or Montauk but also wants to
wear a cashmere crewneck or wants to
wear a top coat we're trying to
incorporate who the Saturdays guy is but
at the same time try and push a lot of
originality with this I wouldn't go too
far away from what you do that's why
like I gravitate into this yeah I saw it
you know this needs to be in there this
I love the idea of a Shetland with your
logo on it I love the idea of a wool
baseball cap nope no problem thank you
all right take care love Center is the
company and the day you looked at yeah I
Ted
why is everything in black too many
hoodies didn't we tell them head to toe
yeah Wow it's not a good champ
johnelliott
what's going on
Johnny Elliot's a rock star he is
influenced by street fashion lifted the
whole idea of monochromatic dressing
head-to-toe we need you to think full
looks six or seven complete looks
head-to-toe I'm just going to struggle
with that well that's okay
so people are fetishizing his clothes
and collecting is closing let's make
sure that they don't get out there too
much in the world so he's going to pull
back a little bit on the designs and the
quantity that's finally delivered this
is not best new menswear designers in
America anymore this is best designers
in America is the celebration of you as
a great American designer so rise to the
occasion and make a killer collection
you know I'm not going to put the GQ
label on anything that's not great and
if you're gonna dial in a collection
that's a little bit watered down I'm not
I'm not that doesn't make me happy you
know I'll make it great and I appreciate
you saying that you said exactly what I
need to hear I'll give you a big hug
when I see you I think we'll get our
looks
totally